[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 30 janvier
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition les yvelines ne sont plus en
alerte orange à la neige et au verglas
après le passage de la tempête gabriel
le département se remet doucement des
intempéries plusieurs milliers de foyers
ont été privés d'électricité cette nuit
mais le courant est revenu peu à peu
dans la journée immersion au sein d'une
opération menée par inédit ce une
période forcément difficile pour les
automobilistes avec une vision réduite
et des chaussées glissantes quel
comportement adopter pour éviter les
mauvaises surprises
nous poserons la question à jean yves
petit directeur du comité des yvelines
de l'association prévention routière et
on compte 4 millions d'adeptes en france
la tendance du lys porte s'empare aussi
du territoire yvelinois dans le
département de nombreux fans des clubs
d'entraînement et des compétitions et
dernière en date le tournoi hairston le
week-end passé à versailles le
département qui s'est donc levé ce matin
avec un épais manteau blanc il est tombé
de 5 à 10 cm de neige dans la nuit et
même jusqu'à 15 cm localement météo
france qui a levé l'alerté orange depuis
ce matin 6h les yvelines reste tout de
même en vigilance jaune avec des
phénomènes de verglas qui pourrait se
produire
cette nuit le mercure devrait de nouveau
descendre avec des températures
négatives de - 3 degrés annoncés
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sortira à ces
engins de salage à partir de 4h30 et
d'ailleurs la préfecture des yvelines a
de nouveau interdite pour la journée de
demain jeudi est la circulation des
transports scolaires la neige mais aussi
les rafales de vents de la tempête
gabriel ont causé de sérieux dégâts dans
le département recense environ 70
interventions de forces de l'ordre et
pompiers des yvelines et des chutes
d'arbres ont également affecté le réseau
d'électricité au plus fort de la crise
sept mille deux cents foyers yvelinois
ont été privés de courant à 17 heures
300 habitations étaient encore concernés
trente agents d'aînés 10 ont donc
profité de cette journée pour assurer le
retour à la normale exemple avec cette
opération à orphin en début d'après midi
suivi par manon varaldo et mélanie poker
nous sommes actuellement à orphin
communes touchées par les coupures
d'électricité suite à la tempête et
gabriel
deux des câbles de moyenne tension sont
tombés cette nuit les équipes des
nahdistes sont sur place sept mille deux
cents personnes étaient coupés
d'électricité à 4 heures du matin quelle
est la situation à la mi-journée à la mi
journée nous avons dans les yvelines
encore 850 personnes qui sont privées
d'électricité
ce qui veut dire que on a rétabli la
très grande majorité de nos clients
déjà ce matin 75 % des clients étaient
déjà avait retrouvé l'électricité
actuellement deux de vos employés sont
en train de réparer les deux câbles
tombés cette nuit
quelles sont leurs actions qu'est ce
qu'ils font nos agents sont arrivés sur
place le plus vite possible pour mettre
en sécurité la zone et réparer les
câbles dans les plus brefs délais
avec tout un matériel adapté à cette
situation
et quelle est la durée d'une telle
intervention alors cette intervention
dure en moyenne autour de trois heures
le temps justement de mettre la zone en
sécurité de monter sur les poteaux à
l'échelle afin de reconnecter les câbles
cassé et de remettre le courant pour
l'ensemble des clients concernés est ce
qu'il ya des risques
alors évidemment nous tenons à rappeler
qu'il ne faut absolument pas s'approcher
des câbles électriques tombés au sol
restez bien à distance éloigner vos
enfants de ces câbles nos équipes
arrivent sur place et interviennent le
plus vite possible pour mettre en
sécurité
nos installations et réparer le courant
30 techniciens d'aînés dix sont
actuellement en intervention dans tout
les yvelines le courant devrait être
rétabli d'ici ce soir
des opérations de rétablissement de
courant forcément bienvenu pour les suds
yvelinois après une nuit difficile
écoutez à ce propos une habitante
d'orphin interrogés sur place également
par manon varaldo et mélanie poker pas
allumer la télé le petit enfin la maison
ils voulaient voir les dessins animés
moi je n'avais plus de deux batteries
sur mon portable donc je peux plus
appelé je peux pas charger mon portable
donc s'il ya une urgence bon bah je suis
pas joignable voilà près c'est vraiment
le frigo si le congélateur là j'ai peur
que bas tout ce qu'il ya dedans bas que
je dois à jeter ou pas enfin je ne sais
pas et la neige a forcément créé des
perturbations aussi sur les réseaux des
transports préventivement la nationale
118 a été fermée toute la nuit elle a
rouvert dans le courant de l'après-midi
les poids lourds interdits de circuler
sur les grands axes 910 camions ont été
stockés le long des voies du département
comme vous le voyez sur ces images prise
ce matin sur l'autoroute a12 et des
problèmes également dans les transports
les lignes n ai eu du transilien
fortement ralenti aujourd'hui le rer c
ne circulaient plus ce matin à saint
quentin en yvelines ni sur la xv
versailles chantiers massy palaiseau en
raison d'arbres tombés sur les rails la
circulation a repris dans la journée
enfin du côté des bus de nombreuses
lignes ne circulait pas ce matin sur le
réseau stibus mais un retour à la
normale est intervenu au cours de cet
après midi jean yves petit est avec nous
sur ce plateau bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le directeur du comité des yvelines de
l'association prévention routière
l'hiver forcément une période difficile
pour les automobilistes vous allez nous
donner quelques conseils pour éviter les
mauvaises surprises
est-ce que le premier conseil déjà à
donner c'est de dire dans la mesure du
possible évitez de prendre votre
véhicule quand il neige et quand il ya
du verglas sur les routes
c'est évidemment ce que j'allais vous
dire en premier donc vous bloquez de la
bouche si on peut éviter de prendre le
volant
oui bien sûr c'était tout le monde le
sait et qui a priori fin surtout pour
les motards
bien évidemment mais eux on les voit pas
trop circuler quand il ya des grilles
des tempêtes de neige mais il est vrai
que moins on sort quand il ya des
épisodes comme ça plus sur scène et si
on est obligé de prendre son véhicule
pour se rendre sur son lieu de travail
parce qu'on n'a pas de solution de
d'autres solutions de transport les le
comportement à adopter va quand il ya de
la neige ça glisse donc levant le pied
allons moins vite et augmentons les
distances de sécurité
je crois que c'est essentiellement sa
essentiellement ça est ce que pour
rouler en cette période il faut
obligatoirement avoir des pneus neige
pneus hiver est ce que c'est un plus
alors oui c'est un plus
évidemment alors chez nous comme les
épisodes neigeux sont quand même assez
rare c'est peut-être pas forcément
indispensable mais il est évident que
c'est un plus si les gens peuvent
changer leurs pneus tant mieux mais
maintenant les routes sûr je pense dans
le département sont suffisamment bien
entretenues on l'a vu aujourd'hui le la
préfecture et les collectivités avaient
pris les mesures pour ça les sables et
donc moi je n'ai pas entendu parler de
problèmes importants sur les routes
les nouvelles opérations sont d'ailleurs
prévues dans la nuit prochaine une
nécessité on le dit au début de chaque
hiver c'est d'être aussi visibles sur
les routes l'hiver puisque les journées
sont plus courtes il faut avoir des feux
qui fonctionne très bien à la rupture
bien sûr ça c'est pas lié à face est pas
lié à la météo bien sûr essayer à la
pério période de deux nuits plus longues
il est évident qu'il faut être bien vu
et bien voir et être bien vu ça concerne
beaucoup les piétons puisqu'il y à de
nombreux accidents de piétons et de
cyclistes qui sont mal vus la nuit et
pas éclairé et qui sont malheureusement
renversés par des voitures non compris
le maître mot c'est la prudence alors on
va profiter votre présence jean yves
petit pour parler d'un autre sujet l
abaissement de la vitesse à 80 km heure
sur les routes secondaires à double sens
et sans séparateur central une mesure
assez impopulaire depuis sa mise en
place le 1er juillet dernier elle lundi
le premier ministre edouard philippe a
dressé un premier bilan as
six mois sans cesse vies ont été
épargnées sur ces routes depuis juillet
une mesure qui marche du coup jean yves
petit on sait que vous étiez pas
forcément convaincu sur l'efficacité au
tout début de la mise en place de cette
mesure alors c'était ce que j'avais dit
effectivement l'année dernière sur votre
plateau maintenant pour revenir d'une
façon un tout petit peu plus générale
sur le 2018
là la baisse du nombre de tués sur les
routes est d'ailleurs du nombre de
blessés du nombre d'accidents d'une
façon générale avait commencé dès le
début de l'année ça n'a pas commencé au
1er juillet puisque depuis 2015 il ya eu
quand même pas mal de mesures qui ont
été mises en oeuvre et en particulier en
2010 18 aussi qui font que la la la
mortalité et les accidents ont baissé
sur la route dès le début de l'année
maintenant pour ce qui concerne le 80 km
nous pensons l'association pense que
pense toujours que c'est une bonne
mesure mais nous pensons qu'il est quand
même un peu trop tôt pour en tirer des
conclusions générales et et définitive
nous redoutions encore loin des
objectifs fixés par le gouvernement 300
à 400 vies épargnées
chaque année on en est on en est encore
loin bien sûr il faut quand même noter
ce que vous n'avez pas dit c'est que les
chiffres annoncés par le premier
ministre sur l'année c'est 3259 tué sait
qui est le plus bas historique nous est
plus bas historique
donc ça c'est quand même c'est quand
même très bien et si plusieurs dizaines
ou centaines de vies ont été épargnées
grâce à l'abaissement de la vitesse sur
les routes secondaires et bien on ne
peut que s'en réjouir
il ya à peu près 600 km dax qui sont
concernés dans les yvelines pour pour
cette mesure du 80 km heure il ya déjà
eu aussi des premiers retours positifs
sur sur la mesure alors en préparant ce
petit entretien j'ai regardé ma même les
statistiques auxquelles j'ai accès et
j'ai pas vu de j'ai pas vu de changement
flagrant entre avant et après le 1er
juillet si vous voulez mais ça reste où
on joue sur des sur des petits nombres
un sûr puisqu'ils en 2018 dans les
yvelines
nous déplorons 49 tués sur la voie
publique dans un accident de la
circulation est exactement le même
nombre qu'en 2017 c'est une mesure je
disais tout à l'heure qui reste assez
impopulaire il fait partie d'ailleurs
des thèmes voulu parler français dans le
grand débat national des possibles
aménagements ont été évoqués par
emmanuel macron et lundi edouard
philippe a jugé légitime d'en discuter
de cette limitation est ce qu'il faut là
juste et cette mesure à votre avis alors
vous souvenez peut-être que l'année
dernière quand vous m'aviez interrogé
là-dessus
j'avais estimé que l'association
soutient la mesure mais on pourrait
quand même s'appuyer davantage sur les
acteurs locaux les préfets un seuil des
29 mai les conseils départementaux les
maires qui eux connaissent leur
territoire et savent bien normalement où
sont les endroits dangereux
on leur fait confiance dans un tas
d'autres domaines ont leur délecte d'un
tas de choses ça me semblerait normal
qu'on les consulte aussi sur les
limitations de vitesse et d'ailleurs le
gouvernement réfléchit à donner la main
à ses conseils départementaux pour
qu'ils agissent au cas par cas selon les
situations sur certaines routes c'est
une bonne chose
donc oui avec le risque quand même enfin
l'inconvénient c'est qu'on va voir se
multiplier les panneaux ce qui est aussi
quelque chose qui est qui est assez
assez mal supporté par nos concitoyens
juste titre on a on a trop de
changements de limitation de vitesse sur
une route sûre sur un certain nombre de
kilomètres on passe du 110 ou 90 77 et
maintenant on ajoute le panneau 80 ça va
encore créer un panneau supplémentaire
donc de la gêne supplémentaire
on va suivre l'évolution en tout cas des
débats sur sur ce thème merci jean yves
petit d'être passé sur ce plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur du
comité des yvelines pour l'association
prévention routière
merci au chapitre de politique c'est
bien à un yvelinois qui conduira les
républicains aux européennes de 2019
françois-xavier bellamy 33 ans a été
désigné tête de liste du parti le nom du
maire adjoint de versailles a été
définitivement arrêtée hier mardi lors
d'une commission nationale d'investiture
il sera accompagnée d'agnès séverin et
de l'ex juppéiste arnaud danjean
respectivement en deuxième et troisième
position est des colistiers renouvelé à
50 % sur les 20 premières places de la
liste
on ne connaît pas d'ailleurs pour le
moment le détail mais françois-xavier
bellamy souhaite rassembler il était ce
matin l'invité de nos confrères de lci
j'ai jamais cru à l'opposition de
l'ancien et du nouveau monde et moi je
crois pas que la jeunesse soit une
qualité en soit je crois pas non plus
qu'être nouveau soit forcément une vertu
je pense qu'il ya une fécondité dans
l'alliance tellement nécessaire entre
eux des idées nouvelles une imagination
et une créativité mais aussi une
expérience une stabilité mes capacités
de comprendre aussi la complexité des
enjeux européens parce que il faut que
les électeurs sachent que ce qui se joue
dans ces élections c
représentation de la france dans des
institutions très complexe et la défense
des intérêts de notre pays et la défense
des intérêts de l'europe
le nom de françois xavier bellamy a été
avancée par le président dlr laurent
laurent wauquiez un choix qui ne fait
pas l'unanimité au sein du parti des
cadres de la formation de droite comme
l'yvelinois gérard larcher ont émis des
réserves quant au profil conservateur du
philosophe qui est un anti mariage pour
tous est un anti ivg
le président du sénat était ce matin
dans les 4 vérités sur france 2 françois
xavier bellamy pour moi il ne cochet pas
il ne coche toujours pas toutes les
cases pour être une tête de liste pour
rassembler une famille politique qui est
diverse
fort d'une carrière dans lequel les
valeurs qu'il peut porter sont
respectables mais ce qui compte avant
tout c'est le projet européen qu'est
l'europe nous voulons une europe qui est
les frontières reconnues en europe qui
gère en même temps la fin du
multilatéralisme avec les états unis
partie la chine et la russie qui se
partagent le monde à 3 la seule réponse
les roms élections européennes programmé
le dimanche 26 mai prochain la commune
de poissy a organisé hier mardi sa
première réunion dans le cadre du grand
débat national de thèmes au programme de
la soirée démocratie et citoyenneté et
fiscalité dépenses publiques des
échanges animés par deux spécialistes du
débat public
récit signé nicolas d'un prix les
français parlent aux français d échange
dans le respect au forum
armand peugeot à poissy la première
soirée organisée par la commune dans le
cadre du grand débat national
pendant trois heures une centaine de
citoyens à échanger sur les institutions
les finances publiques et sur des
thématiques libre l'ensemble des
pisciacais et des pisciacais les
habitants de poissy veulent s'exprimer
et ils veulent s'exprimer comme ils
s'expriment dans le cadre du quotidien
avec les collègues élus que nous sommes
ici à pau si ils veulent de l'expression
directe ils veulent pas forcément des
thèmes imposés
c'est pour ça que j'ai souhaité qu'ils
aient des thèmes libres également et on
l'a vu ce soir
on peut ne pas être d'accord des
désaccords notamment sur l'allongement
de l'âge du départ à la retraite mais
aussi des convergences sur la volonté de
transparence et de participation des
citoyens dans les décisions politiques
j'ai vu des gens passionnés par la
politique et moi ça fait 15 ans que je
vote c'est la première fois que je vois
autant de gens
intéressé par un petit que ça me donne
de l'espoir de voir les gens s'impliquer
autant évaluation des réformes renforcer
la décentralisation ou supprimer le cic
e pour les grandes entreprises
de nombreuses propositions émises durant
la soirée les yeux lui par rapport à
leurs concitoyens qui n'est pas de
verticalité comme ça a été dit et donc
qu'ils puissent avoir un échange entre
associations et élus pour l'intérêt
général celui que j'avais un souci avec
le mécanisme d'impôt sur le revenu tels
que la liste actuellement lorsque je
pense qu'il est totalement injuste
incompréhensible qui devrait mis à plat
complètement pour être beaucoup plus
citoyen est beaucoup plus égalitaire
de mon point de vue il n'y absolument
aucune différence entre un euro que vous
percevez à travers un salaire ou une
pension est un héros percevait à travers
une subvention ou une prime qui vient de
l'état donc je pense mais 2 devrait être
fiscalisés prochain rendez vous mardi 5
février au théâtre de poissy avec au
programme la transition écologique et
l'organisation de l'état à saint germain
en laye les 11 députés yvelinois de la
majorité présidentielle ont présenté
récemment leurs voeux c'était au manège
royal avec la présence de la secrétaire
d'état à la transition écologique brune
poirson
les parlementaires ont chacun leur tour
fait un bilan de leurs actions sur
plusieurs réformes de 2018 est
l'occasion aussi d'évoquer la
contestation des gilet jaune et la
réponse apportée par le président de la
république au travers du grand débat
national
les propos sont recueillis par nicolas
landry on a eu une activité
parlementaire extrêmement intense avec
des grandes réformes qui fixe les jalons
de notre politique publique et que nous
comptons mener sur plusieurs années et
donc en fin d'année 2010 8 un petit peu
perturbé parce que nous avons bien senti
que le rythme auquel nous nous étions
habitués depuis l'arrivée en
responsabilité eh bien peut-être que ça
allait un petit peu trop vite ce
mouvement citoyen extrême une colère il
faut l'entendre nous l'avons entendu et
c'est ce qui donne lieu à ce grand débat
national qui s'ouvre
pour effectivement faire le constat de
ce qui ne va pas et voir les
propositions qui émerge la suite de
notre dossier de la semaine sur la
solidarité dans les yvelines après avoir
fait la connaissance des bénévoles
partons à la rencontre des bénéficiaires
elles sont plus de 13000 personnes
accueillies par exemple par les restos
du coeur des yvelines portrait de l'une
d'entre elles qui se rend une fois par
semaine à l'antenne de rambouillet ces
signes et marylène yapi chinois une fois
par semaine marie laure miro se rend au
centre des restos du coeur de
rambouillet bonjour vous allez bien un
rendez vous pour lequel elle a ses
habitudes
les sacs de près comme chaque
bénéficiaire des restos du coeur elle
était accompagnée d'un bénévoles qui
l'aident à composer son panier en
fonction du nombre de points dont elle
dispose pour elle et son fils alors là
oui on donne la viande donc on nous
propose un peu de sueur foulée et du
frais une fois le caddie plein marie
laure a pour habitude de rester pour un
café l échange avec les bénévoles et les
autres bénéficiaires qui la connaissent
bien
il ya deux ans marie laure subi de
lourdes opérations entraînant des arrêts
de travail prolongé auxiliaire de
puériculture elle ne peut plus porter
d'enfant elle est reconnue travailleuse
handicapée
la microcrèche pour laquelle elle
travaille là les sensibles pour
inaptitude physique est très difficile
pour moi parce que du jour au lendemain
mais j'ai perdu mon mon métier
et puis mon envie d'exercer c'était une
passion pour moi sa pension d'invalidité
de deuxième catégorie 2 544 euros par
mois et son allocation retour à l'emploi
d'environ 180 euros par mois
l'aide mais ne suffisent pas plus que
des paniers alimentaires les restos du
coeur lui ont apporté du soutien dans
cette épreuve difficile
la joint l'espérance
et puis nous redonne à un punch
formidable humble parce que quand on est
un peu déprimé et tout il arrive à nous
nous sortir la tête de l'eau disons pas
cela j'ai fait le tricot mais ça fait
aussi tricot thérapie au pinceau marie
laure n'a jamais perdu le sourire grâce
à l'aide de son chien nacho et de son
fils vincent avec lequel elle entretient
une grande complicité
tous deux ont pu assister à un spectacle
au théâtre des champs elysées offert par
les restos du coeur on a eu des fous
rires avec mon fils et mon ami qui lui
reste du coeur aussi qui est mike qui
était venu avec nous alors voilà la
fameuse photo avec un fou-rire pour
marie laure et son fils la situation
s'est améliorée
elle a retrouvé un emploi adapté à son
handicap elle est d'un enfant autiste
dans son programme scolaire 20 heures
par semaine avec ce revenu
supplémentaire plus besoin de se rendre
aux restos du coeur
elle tient à laisser sa place à d'autres
personnes dans le besoin ils font
tellement chose pour nous que je vous
dire on les remercie pas par l'argent
mais on les remercie par des petits
gestes etc
c'est les way je suis venu parce que
c'est des gens mais formidable mais
alors le mercredi jour de notre
traditionnelle visite dans les cinémas
du coin focus ce soir sur la
programmation du ciné 7 à elancourt
c'est au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude cette semaine au ciné cette un
large éventail de films à voir ou à
revoir jeudi à revoir parce que toujours
à la fiche bohemian rhapsody le fûmes
phénomène qui raconte une partie de la
vie du groupe bull et de son leader donc
toujours à l'affiché de crevettes et les
gens lee qui sont déjà venus boire
quatre cinq six fois donc on continue à
diffuser deviendra absolue et puis
surtout centré nationale très attendue
paraît-il
qu'est-ce qu'on a encore fait au bon
dieu avec christian clavier notamment
donc succès attendu de l'année 2019 mais
aussi la mule le très bon thriller on va
dire sentimentale de clint eastwood
qu'on n'avait pas vu à l'écran 88 ans
clint eastwood avait pas vu à l'écran
depuis longtemps donc il reprend son
rôle un peu de personnages bougon qui
n'en fait qu'à sa tête
c'est assez savoureux et puis aux 6 à
pickering
alors ça c'est un film qui raconte
l'histoire de la vie d'oscar wilde et il
passe pour très peu de ça ils venaient
le voir c'est un fils de rupert everett
on n'est pas sûrs sylvain depuis
longtemps avec toute perte everett et
pour les plus petits en avant-première
dimanche matin à 10h30 et le très
attendu aussi ralph et 2.0 est aussi le
très joli manga japonais mirail ma
petite soeur qu'il voudrait voir style
semaine sur nos écrans
[Musique]
mélanie pocket avec moi sur ce plateau
bonsoir en sarre pas de coup de coeur
culture ce soir ça c'est le mardi
vous venez nous parler de sport
électronique ou plutôt de heath porte
des compétitions des clubs
d'entraînement et des fans de jeux vidéo
peuvent pratiquer leur passion dans les
yvelines
alors avant de parler du département
quelques chiffres l'ispor c'est un
marché qui grandit d'année en année en
2018 il est estimé à plus de 900
millions de dollars c'est près de 300
millions de plus que l'année précédente
en france les joueurs réguliers seraient
environ 400 milles et un millier d'entre
eux seraient professionnelle et du coup
est ce que les yvelines sont concernés
et oui pas plus tard que le week-end
dernier à versailles se tenait la
deuxième édition du tournoi heures stone
alors c'est un jeu de cartes à
collectionner en ligne un jeu gratuit
qui s'inspire de l'univers de warcraft
alors il y à autant de genres différents
qu'il y a de jeu et au mois de septembre
aubergenville un club d'entraînement
s'est lancé ils sont encadrés puisque il
ya des coachs qui viennent régulièrement
leur faire des séances d'entraînement
donc c'est à la charge de ses coaches de
leur donner des nouvelles techniques ou
en tout cas une nouvelle vision sur le
jeu pour justement s'améliorer et
s'aguerrir et participer aux plus belles
compétitions
c'est vrai que moi j'ai plutôt un
passionné de fifa dans ce club on joue
d'ailleurs à cheval mais aussi à dragon
ball à quoi ressemble un entraînement et
en fait ils en ont de différents types
mais qui ressemble à un entraînement de
sports traditionnels on va dire alors ça
dure trois heures deux fois une heure et
demie d entraînement technique et
sportif avec des conseils notamment de
maintien du corps dont il faut prendre
soin c'est le ses larmes pour jouer ce
soir-là il travaillait plutôt le mental
avec leur coach ils s'appellent alix du
lag c'est un ancien joueur professionnel
mais qui est toujours dans le circuit il
est aussi journaliste ispa leur
expliquer en matinée quelle ambiance
l'otan doit les préparer
beaucoup de préparation mentale et
ensuite en match vraiment corriger les
rats pour qu'ils puissent faire le le
plus de match presque parfait parce que
jamais le match parfait car actuellement
le plus jeune joueur compétiteurs de la
team à 11 ans le plus âgé en a 27 et
leur but de cette année aller à la
gamers assemblée qui se déroule du 20 au
22 avril à poitiers à faire assure merci
mélanie pour cette chronique qui on
referme d'ailleurs ce journal avec
d'autres geek à voisins le bretonneux le
dernier salon warhammer s'est ouvert à
d'autres aspects de la pop culture le
week-end dernier parmi les nombreuses
animations proposées un escape game sur
le thème d'harry potter
marylène iapichino et mickaël millero
ont enfilé leur cap
une entrée dans la chambre des secrets
pour son salon pop culture le centre
alfred de vigny accueille un escape game
harry potter au fil de cette escale
games est en fait de sauver la nièce du
professeur pan tilt qui a été accusé à
tort d'avoir d'avoir fait plein de
mauvaises blagues au ministère de la
magie il mois et en fait c'est un
camarade de classe qui a voulu lui jouer
un tour et ça c'est mal tourné est en
fait il faut qu'elle prouve son
innocence
ballan doivent justement allumé un hack
le bâton magique la lumière noire
on est dans le noir il sait trouver les
indices sur la punition les plus
magiques sont interdites en examen
espérant qu'on trouvait lundi
attendez la trace ont entouré l'équipe
recherche et décrypte les indices pour
achever cette première étape
la seconde salle de rette ouverte
seulement deux équipes sont arrivés
jusque là durant le week-end elle était
difficile mais on a réussi et
c'était très bien son salon spécialisé
warhammer s'essoufflant le centre alfred
de vigny a décidé cette année de
s'étendre à la pop culture pour ses
premiers à fred héros style des
animations autour des univers de harry
potter et star wars des conférences des
concerts des stands de passionner les
activités variées sur les deux jours et
j'ai vu des jeunes que je vois toute
l'année alors de notre autre autres
activités venir cosplay et avec des
petits accessoires et qui sont venus
parler de leur passion qui ont osé se
montrer comme il le ferait pas dans le
reste de l'année
donc j'espère que ça se renouvelle au
total plus de 200 personnes sont venues
explorer les facettes de la pop culture
à voisins le bretonneux ce week end
c'est la fin de ce journal dans un
instant ne manquez pas le retour du 7-8
débat belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]